this video is sponsored by Mel science
science topics often pull us in but our
limit on what we know can make us lose
interest science is about exploration
Discovery and asking questions there's
an element of childlike Wonder in all of
us that makes us ask why sometimes the
best way to know why is to find out with
an experiment this brings me to the
sponsor of today's video Mel science Mel
science creates monthly science boxes
for children and teens which involve
Hands-On experiments combined with VR
and AR Technologies they have a variety
of subjects in chemistry biology
medicine math coding and more metal
science's goal is to make science more
accessible and share The Stereotype that
science is boring hard or just for nerds
Mel science goes the extra mile with
their science kits I was surprised to
see that they had a pharmacy kit that
came with high quality labware that you
wouldn't find in most kits I was able to
make my own fizzy tablets and do a
compound identification test in a
separate chemistry kit I made crystals
from iodine Vapors which was pretty cool
you can use their app to follow along
with each experiment the directions are
straightforward and easy to use I had a
lot of fun doing these experiments and I
think the kids in your life or the kid
and you will enjoy them too you can get
50 off the first month by clicking the
link in the description check out mail
science today
most people don't think about carbon
monoxide poisoning on a daily basis the
most common dangerous topics among the
Talking Heads Are murder terrorism drugs
poverty and disease relative to the
threats on your mortality carbon
monoxide poisoning is very low with
about 430 fatalities per year in the U.S
yet if you look to Hollywood carbon
monoxide poisoning is often represented
in film despite its wide use in media
it's hardly understood in this video
I'll be covering the dark science of
carbon monoxide poisoning
foreign
[Music]
the carbon monoxide molecule consists of
a carbon atom triple bonded to an oxygen
atom carbon monoxide is not to be
confused with carbon dioxide the gaseous
molecule you exhale as a result of
metabolism carbon dioxide is made of a
carbon atom double bonded to two oxygen
both molecules share similar properties
they're both gaseous at room temperature
have no color no taste and no smell one
major difference though is that carbon
dioxide is not toxic and carbon monoxide
is carbon monoxide is toxic when it's
inhaled due to its effect on the
function of hemoglobin hemoglobin is a
vital protein embedded in your red blood
cells and is responsible for carrying
and releasing oxygen in your blood on
hemoglobin there are four protein
segments called hem groups with an iron
atom in the center when red blood cells
pass through a circulation in your lungs
inhaled oxygen diffuses into the
bloodstream and encounters the
hemoglobin protein oxygen then by binds
to each heme group resulting in four
oxygen molecules to one hemoglobin
protein once oxygen is bound to
hemoglobin it's renamed to oxyhemoglobin
red blood cells transport the
oxyhemoglobin throughout the body to
tissues that require oxygen oxygen then
leaves heme groups when hemoglobin is
exposed to blood that is somewhat acidic
blood becomes acidic when there is high
concentrations of carbon dioxide in the
blood gaseous carbon dioxide reacts with
water forming carbonic acid and makes
the blood slightly acidic high
concentrations of carbon dioxide in
blood is due to increased metabolism
such as exercise or stress the more
carbon dioxide you generate the more
oxygen gets released into the blood the
system works perfectly until carbon
monoxide is present then things go
horribly wrong the degree of how strong
or weak two molecules bind is called
Affinity Oxygen's affinity for
hemoglobin is measured in millimeters of
mercury and is about 27 units this is a
fair really weak Affinity but
intentionally because oxygen has to be
able to leave hemoglobin at a moment's
notice carbon monoxide's affinity for
hemoglobin is much higher at 65
millimeters of mercury or 240 times
stronger than oxygen this stronger
Affinity keeps carbon monoxide bound to
hemoglobin much more tightly than oxygen
and it doesn't let go for about five
hours
carbon monoxide's first effect on the
body is when it binds to a heme group on
hemoglobin once bounded it takes the
place of an oxygen molecule allowing
only three oxygen to bind instead of
four it should also be noted when carbon
monoxide binds to hemoglobin hemoglobin
is renamed to carboxyhemoglobin due to
its different properties one notable
property is that the molecule itself
produces a bright cherry red color which
is a Telltale sign of carbon monoxide
poisoning one who has inhaled a
significant amount of carbon monoxide
will have a cherry red Hue to their skin
this is because a large amount of
hemoglobin in their blood has been
converted to carboxyhemoglobin
unfortunately by the time the skin has
identifiable color the victim is usually
deceased due to the high concentrations
in the blood taking the place of oxygen
on hemoglobin isn't the only thing
carbon monoxide does it also affects the
other oxygen indirectly as well the
charge on carbon monoxide stabilizes the
iron ion in the center of the protein
when iron becomes stabilized it changes
the physical shape of the heme groups as
a result the oxygen molecules stay fixed
to the heme groups as long as carbon
monoxide is also present in essence
oxygen cannot be used by the body as a
result the oxygen cannot be released
into the blood causing asphyxiation or
deprivation of oxygen early symptoms of
asphyxiation first manifest as flu-like
symptoms such as headache weakness and
dizziness as more carbon monoxide is
inhaled symptoms progress to chest pain
vomiting confusion irregular heartbeat
and loss of consciousness once
unconsciousness is reached all that's
left is for the brain to shut down and
then it's over
depending on the concentration of carbon
monoxide fatal effects may happen within
minutes or hours the low end of fatal
concentrations begin at 3 200 parts per
million and can cause death within 30
minutes at 12 800 parts per million
fatal effects can occur within three
minutes or less in contrast lethal
concentrations of carbon dioxide is
about 40 000 parts per million because
carbon dioxide is not toxic there just
has to be enough to displace available
oxygen
whereas carbon monoxide directly shuts
down oxygen distribution carbon monoxide
is also less dense than oxygen and
carbon dioxide meaning it will diffuse
throughout a room fairly well instead of
settling near the ground we know how
carbon monoxide poisoning works but
where does it come from
carbon monoxide is produced when there
is a low amount of oxygen during a
combustion reaction in combustion
reactions hydrocarbons are burned in the
presence of oxygen resulting in the
formation of water and carbon dioxide if
there's not enough oxygen present there
won't be enough to make carbon dioxide
instead the reaction will still proceed
but only one oxygen will bind to carbon
instead of two making water and carbon
monoxide low oxygen combustion reactions
typically occur when something is
burning in a closed space where there is
a low amount of oxygen available the
most common occurrence of this is an
internal combustion engine being run in
a closed space such as a garage carbon
monoxide can also occur in your own home
when furnace ventilation gets blocked
which is a common occurrence in the
winter charcoal is also known to release
significant amounts of carbon monoxide
during its combustion and was famously
used as a means of by K-pop singer Chung
Young there is another occurrence of
carbon monoxide poisoning in everyday
life that millions of people partake in
smoking inhaling smoke from both burning
tobacco and cannabis delivers carbon
monoxide directly into the blood whether
it's rolled in paper or in a pipe the
combustion does not burn with sufficient
oxygen and therefore produces carbon
monoxide there is enough carbon monoxide
in cigarette and cannabis smoke to
develop mild carbon monoxide poisoning
depending on how much is smoked per day
in a study from the Spanish clinical
Journal 228 smokers were tested for
carbon monoxide presence in their blood
the average non-smoker has a one percent
carbon monoxide concentration in their
blood from biological production and
small concentrations in the air in
contrast smokers who had between 1 in 10
cigarettes per day had a blood carbon
monoxide concentration of 5.2 percent
those who smoked more than 20 cigarettes
per day had a 9 9.6 percent
concentration blood levels of 10 percent
or higher is defined as carbon monoxide
poisoning symptoms that chronic smokers
have such as fatigue headache shortness
of breath and confusion are more likely
than not the effects of mild carbon
monoxide poisoning in fact chronic
smokers have more hemoglobin in their
blood than a non-smoker as their body
has to make more to compensate for
hemoglobin that's been inactivated
despite how dangerous carbon monoxide
poisoning is if caught quickly it can be
treated patients are given oxygen
through breathing masks or if necessary
placed in hyperbaric oxygen Chambers
where they breathe nearly pure oxygen
high concentrations of oxygen cause
carbon monoxide to unbind from the heme
groups much faster reducing the time
it's attached from five hours to about
an hour and a half
with carbon monoxide Unbound oxygen can
bind and unbind from hemoglobin as
normal
sometimes science can be seen as
difficult foreign and even boring yet
there are times when science grabs our
attention and draws Us in yearning for
more answers often what draws us Center
topics that are dark Macabre or
terrifying it's with the intention of
this video that you too were drawn in
and sought to have your questions
answered thanks for watching Dark
science
[Music]